et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
patrick mignola bonjour bonjour si
beaucoup d'être avec nous député de la
savoie président du groupe modem à
l'assemblée nationale on est ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par julien lécuyer
de la voix du nord bonjour julien
bonjour oriane bonjour monsieur lignes
rouges ont survécu et on va commencer
patrick mignola avec cette manifestation
mobilisation des policiers hier devant
l'assemblée nationale le ministre de
l'intérieur et plusieurs politiques de
tous bords d'ailleurs sont allés les
soutenir pour quoi vous n'y étiez pas
vous parce que j'ai enchaîné les rendez
vous dans mon bureau mais il y avait
évidemment une délégation du groupe
modem qui est allé à leurs côtés parce
que c'était c'était avant tout une
manifestation de soutien
il y avait beaucoup d'émotion suite aux
assassinats d'éric masson de stéphanie
mon fermé donc c'était bien que les
politiques soient là et tout ce qui m'a
oui je crois c'était une logique
d'ailleurs que le miz de l'intérieur
soit soit au milieu de ses troupes
pas de la récupération politique c'est
ça qui m'a gêné un peu au fond je pense
que c'était bien d'amener des
délégations de toutes les familles
politiques hormis les insoumis qui comme
d'habitude ont voulu se singulariser en
mauvais terme d'ailleurs ce que je n'ai
pas aimé ce mois ils ont travaillé dans
ce sens sur le sujet de cinq sièges
voilà il ya rien de factieux dans un
défilé qui à la fois dit de l'émotion
dit qu'il a besoin de plus de moyens
pour la police et dit qu'il a besoin
d'une réponse judiciaire plus efficace
est-ce que tu as certainement ne vous
ont pas choqué quand par exemple le
secrétaire général du syndicat alliance
dit que le problème c'est la justice
alors moi ce qui m'a un peu ennuyé c'est
que dans la séquence discours que j'ai
pu suivre de loin on avait l'impression
de discours très politique et pas les
discours qui parlait simplement du
quotidien des policiers et de
l'efficacité de l'action mais je vais
vous dire ça m'a choqué aussi d'avoir
autant de politique parce que c'est bien
d'avoir des délégations de tous les
courants de pensée de tous les
mouvements politiques mais il ya un
certain nombre de gens qui sont venus
déploré les conséquences des décisions
qu'ils ont prises pendant dix ans parce
que nous on n'a certainement pas encore
fait assez pour les policiers pour leur
équipement pour leurs moyens pour
l'efficacité de leurs actions sur le
terrain mais après tout c'est quand même
bien
le quinquennat sarkozy puis le
quinquennat hollande qui avait réduit
les moyens des policiers de façon
drastique
et finalement ce sont ceux qui avaient
voté dans les assemblées moi je n'y
siégerai pas à l'époque
c'est ce qu'avait votée dans les
assemblées la baisse des budgets de la
police de la gendarmerie des pompiers
qui sort du défilé pour dénoncer les
conséquences des décisions qu'ils
avaient eux-mêmes votée au parlement
donc il ya un côté récupération il ya
aussi une certaine forme d'impudeur à
mes yeux se créent des finances est ce
qu'il n'ya pas aussi quelque chose de
presque gênant de voir ministre de
l'intérieur venir au soutien d'une
manifestation qui clairement met en
cause son confrère eric dupond moretti
et qui appelle même à le siffler alors
pas le ministre de l'intérieur mais les
syndicats policiers
ça fait très longtemps de toute façon
dans ce pays où c'est moi j'ai été élu
municipal à partir de 1995
et ça fait longtemps qu'on ressent tous
le fait que sur le terrain quand la
police quand la gendarmerie quand les
polices municipales arrive à dénouer une
enquête
la réponse judiciaire n'est pas assez
rapide et elle n'est pas assez forte
c'est comme ça que un petit délinquant
peut devenir un grand truand parce que à
la fois vous pouvez vous retrouver avec
un acte délictueux on a identifié le
fauteur de troubles mais qui n'est jugé
qu'au bout de deux ou trois ans c'est
celui qui vole un vélo à 13 ans s'il est
jugé à 16 ans entre temps il a eu le
temps de devenir beaucoup plus grands
délinquants ou éventuellement d'avoir
repris le droit chemin
donc soit viable parce qu'elle a la
réponse judiciaire sert à rien c'est une
question de rapidité
et puis parfois n'y a pas de réponse du
tout c'est ce qui évidemment pose
problème parce qu'on ne peut pas
travailler sur le terrain entre élus
locaux et forces de l'ordre
et puis avoir ou qui ont conseillé de
comptabilité et fermeté mais est ce que
ça voulait dire par exemple que vous
êtes favorable aux peines plancher alors
moi je crois pas du tout aux peines
planchers puisque je rappelle que la
décision qui avait été prise sur les
peines planchers 7 en cas de récidive
oui sur la question dramatique tragique
profonde de la protection des forces de
l'ordre et plus globalement des
personnes dépositaires de l'autorité
publique
ça peut être les policiers ça peut être
les pompiers ça peut être les maires ces
petits agents administratifs
parce que les agressions contre le les
personnes qui sont à l'accueil de la caf
ou qui sont à l'accueil de pôle emploi
c'est tous les jours que ça se passe il
faut remettre de l'autorité dans ce pays
que vont se remettre la tête à l'endroit
il faut que quand on agresse quelqu'un
qui est dépositaire de l'autorité
publique on sache que on va être
sanctionné plus au delà des sanctions
qui sont habituellement donnés dans
d'autres formes d'agression je trouve ça
parfaitement normal mais dans ce cas là
ça veut dire qu'il faut amplifier la
peine dès le premier acte délictueux
plutôt parler de peines plancher qui
sont devenus une espèce de deux mots
valises de récurrence de laïcs motif de
la classe politique ambiant on regarde
et on met des peines planchers la classe
politique les syndicats de police a
souligné m
les syndicats de police il demande une
réponse pénale qui soit rapide efficace
minimal de plus grande ampleur de plus
grande ampleur que les peines
aujourd'hui quand la justice passe elle
définit une peine d'un mois je pense que
cette peine
elle doit être supérieur lorsqu'on
s'attaque à quelqu'un qui est
dépositaire de l'autorité publique et
préciser moi hier c'était une affaire de
circonstances plus que de pressions des
policiers qui étaient devant l'assemblée
nationale
on a voté dans l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale le fait qu' il ya
un an lorsqu'il ya un meurtre d'un
policier
c'était 30 ans la peine ça je trouve que
c'est une véritable avancée parce qu'on
va au delà des mots parce que c'est
évidemment normal qu'il puisse y avoir
des manifestations quand même énorme
parution et 30 pour une réponse on parle
de crime monsieur mignola ça veut dire
que vous vous souhaitez qu'on aille même
plus loin que les annonces qui ont été
faites par le premier ministre auprès
des syndicats policiers et puis je moi
je croyais alors il a parlé des
policiers moi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
réfléchisse à toutes les personnes qui
sont dépositaires de l'autorité publique
dans le pays il faut que vous protégiez
ce qui vous protège il faut que vous
protégiez toutes celles et ceux qui
prennent des responsabilités sur le
terrain de 500 habitants pour les lycées
agressé comme quand vous avez un
conseiller pôle emploi qui prend un coup
de poing dans la figure parce que il a
une personne face à lui qui ne
respectent plus rien il faut que la
réponse de la société soit forte et que
très tranquillement la justice parce
qu'elle passe plus vite et c'est pour ça
qu'on lui donne plus de moyens c'est à
17 % d'augmentation du budget
le juge si ça n'est jamais arrivé jamais
dans l'histoire de la vème république et
que à chaque fois on donne ce message à
la société des responsabilités si vous
vous attaquez à eux françois là et donc
c'est une femme protection des élus
c'est simplement de se dire que pendant
que la république les forces
républicaines vous souhaitez que ça
aille plus loin comment vous allez faire
en sorte de mettre en oeuvre ce que vous
allez faire quoi des vous allez proposer
des amis c'est ce que nous avons fait et
moi je j'ai proposé s'ils le veulent
bien aux responsables des syndicats de
police qui viennent rencontrer le groupe
de démocrates à l'assemblée et qu'on
puisse travailler avec eux au delà des
mots et des discours politiques parfois
exacerbée voire exagérée qu'ont pu avoir
lieu dans la manifestation d'hier on va
les rencontrer
quand on va travailler avec eux dans les
semaines qui viennent la mesure de leur
envoyer un courrier hier hier soir en
leur disant maintenant on se rencontre
on a envoyé une délégation à vos côtés
pour vous soutenir et pour montrer qu'on
a la même émotion que vous sur les faits
très graves qui se sont déroulées au
cours des dernières semaines maintenant
remontons nous les hanches et faisons en
sorte que l'on refasse pas dans un an
la même manifestation parce que les
choses ont avancé et ça aboutira sur
quoi une composition de la
éventuellement le nom on peut venir sur
le budget prochain on peut venir sur les
prochains textes je pense le plat sur le
texte justice une fois qu'on l'aura voté
à la fin de cette semaine ce que
j'entends bien qu'il soit voté ensuite
il viendra au sénat et en deuxième
lecture
il faut qu'on continue à progresser et
qu'on montre à chacun que les
parlementaires sont au rendez-vous et à
l'écouté du terrain et des professions
on va parler notre actualitté dans notre
taxe et le texte sur la sortie
progressive de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire les députés l'ont voté la
semaine dernière les sénateurs l'on
votait la nuit précédente mais en le
modifiant ce texte ils ont notamment
prolongé l'état d'urgence actuelle dans
mois et raccourcit le régime transitoire
de 15 jours par rapport aux députés
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
version des sénateurs
aulas le texte va revenir à l'assemblée
il ya une discussion qui est une
discussion surtout juridique sur la
notion d'état d'urgence puisque
dans le calendrier qui a été proposée
par le président de la république un
calendrier de sortie progressive mais
qui est assez clair dans l'esprit des
français ont cette date après date
quand on va pouvoir lever les
contraintes et on a commencé à le faire
hier avec l'ouverture des terrasses
la question est ce que le cadre
juridique nécessite que jusqu'au 30 juin
nous restions sous l'état d'urgence
parce qu'on utilise le couvre-feu ou
est-ce que nous levons l'état d'urgence
au 15 juin
mais qu'on a des dispositions
spécifiques au couvre-feu nous on avait
fait le deuxième choix
ce qui fait que le la cmp n'aboutira
probablement pas le texte va revenir à
l'assemblée on voit un préalable
important alors le mémo gg j'avais suivi
avec intérêt un amendement qui avait été
déposé par par mon ami arrêt marseille
au nom du groupe centriste puisque nous
comme vous le savez on s'était engagés à
l'assemblée pour que l'on réduise le
délai des dispositions d'urgence et
qu'on le mette au 30 septembre plutôt
qu'au 31 octobre ça nous paraissait
lointain et puis y avait un deuxième
sujet c'est qu'il fallait une mesure en
faveur des jeunes y avait un dernier
secteur économique qui n'avait pas été
réouverte et celui des discothèques des
boîtes de nuit alors que finalement on
avait autorisé beaucoup d'autres
activités comme les soirées de mariage
les soirées d'anniversaire vous
finalement il fallait qu'on avance sur
ce sujet le groupe centriste au sénat
avait repris l'amendement qu'on avait
déposé il a été finalement retoqué si
j'ai bien compris au titre de l'article
41 pour des raisons réglementaires alors
que je vois pas ce que red réglementaire
en l'occurrence ce serait l'utilisation
du pass sanitaire pourrait ouvrir les
discothèques
c'est bien la loi c'est pas le règlement
donc on avancera sur ce sujet là après
le lie à une discussion juridique à une
discussion politique la discussion
juridique c'est 15 juin au 30 juin ça on
l'aura l'assemblée en tout cas on se met
pas d'accord dans les termes qui sont
ceux du sénat il ya une décision
politique
est ce qu'on est capable de réouvrir
aussi le dernier secteur économique
fermé et d'envoyer un message positif
aux jeunes moi je pense qu'il y manquait
quelque chose pour les jeunes dans cette
loi mais ce mignola rébénacq il faut
qu'on le fasse et nous reprendrons après
qu'il l'ait repris la proposition des
centristes mais derrière on a bien senti
que le groupe modem avait une forte
envie d'aller danser
mais est-ce qu'ils n'avaient pas si
c'est rien je suis pas très boîte de
nuit
en plus c'était s'était pas vraiment à
titre personnel non mes enfants c'était
bien oui oui et notion de d'encadrement
gelé entendu de la part des
propriétaires de discothèques mais plus
sérieusement est-ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi
derrière ce combat ce cheval de bataille
l'occasion de rappeler à la république
en marche que vous étiez des partenaires
qu' il y avait peut-être besoin aussi de
vous écouter et que si on ne nous
écoutait pas eh bien vous aviez moyen de
ne pas faire laissez passer certains
textes
ben vous avez parfaitement raison merci
mais ça il faut pas faire de langue de
bois sur ces sujets là on est dans une
majorité parlementaire qui est diverse
avec des courants politiques différents
quand on tient à des sujets c'est
important qu'on puisse en parler ne pas
être traité par le silence sinon par le
mépris mépris en tout cas il n'y avait
pas de réponse est donc moi je ne porte
pas de jugement je pense pas
d'interprétation
ce que je sais c'est quand on est
partenaire dans une majorité on discute
ensemble pour définir comment on va
pouvoir enrichir un texte c'est le rôle
du parlement de premier ministre et l'a
compris soeur de compris le premier
village rue mardi mais qu'est-ce qui
c'est le comment vous lui avait expliqué
la semaine dernière le premier ministre
avait compris on avait échangé
d'ailleurs après cette petite cette
petite épisode de tension par le garder
dans quelques heures on avait on avait
évidemment régler le problème et trouver
la solution et christophe castaner et et
jean castex
la question c'est une affaire de modem
je vais vous dire la question c'est que
le président de la république dont je
souhaite la réélection ne sera pas en
2022 réélu je le crois comme il a été
élu en 2017 et qui nous faut ouvrir
cette majorité à de nouvelles alliances
il ya des élus et des électeurs surtout
qu'ils sont à gauche gêné par les
dérives racialiste d'une gauche qui a
abandonné l'universalisme
il ya des électeurs de droite qui sont
malheureux de voir la course à la droite
qui est en train de faire le
le party les républicains si nous
voulons nous ouvrir à ceux de ces
nouvelles alliances
il faut déjà qu'on se respecte entre
alliés d'aujourd'hui si les alliés
d'aujourd'hui se respecte pas comment
trouver et comment attirer de nouveaux
alliés demain donc c'est aussi une
affaire de méthode c'est pas seulement
la question de savoir si on se regarde
suffisamment dans le blanc des yeux
entre la république en marche et le
modem c'est de se dire si demain on tend
la main à droite et à gauche pour
élargir cette majorité pour reconstruire
ensemble le pays il faut déjà qu'on
montre que la majorité d'aujourd'hui
elle fonctionne et qu'elle est capable
de respecter la diversité c'est aussi ça
qu'on a dit la semaine est-ce que c'est
pas une manière finalement de dire à la
majorité sans nous enfin le majeur car
elle est l'héroïne sans nous vous ne
gagnerez pas cette élection en 2022
c'est surtout que nous disions à
l'ensemble des forces de la majorité
aujourd'hui que elles ne peuvent pas
s'enfermer dans un splendide isolement
et que le but
l'année prochaine ce sera de rassembler
très largement les français et ne pas
rester enfermé sur nous-mêmes et c'était
aujourd'hui il y avait un peu de
suffisance de la part de la république
en marche alors je le dis pas en termes
génériques céphale la république en
marche mais vous avez toujours la
tentation surtout d'ailleurs dans les
périodes électorales où on prépare les
départementales et régionales vous avez
toujours la tentation du parti unique
c'est la gauche a essayé la droite a
essayé on sait comment ça finit
moi je crois que dans une démocratie
moderne
quand on arrive à trouver une maturité
politique on accepte que des personnes
différentes des courants de pensée
différents puissent travailler ensemble
eh bien c'est ce travail là qu'un
travail quotidien qu'il faut sans cesse
remettre sur le métier qu'on doit être
capable de faire dans toutes les
familles dans toutes les associations
dans toutes les entreprises ont toutes
les administrations et des personnes qui
pensent différemment et il arrive à
travailler ensemble
pourquoi le champ politique ne
parviendrait pas on doit être capable de
bâtir une majorité qui va comme disait
françois bayrou il ya quelques années de
dollars à balladur on dire aujourd'hui
de valse à philippe et probablement un
peu au delà de valser un peu au delà de
philippe dans ces conditions là on va
quand même pas se bisbilles
et contre la république en marche et le
modem si demain au contraire il faut
qu'on travaille aussi avec d'autres
aujourd'hui vous êtes encore le modem
est encore aujourd'hui je vous qui vous
posez la question je me la pose pas
allier kita qui est à servir du
bulldozer c'est comme ça qu'on vous
appelle vous avez vu l'article du figaro
dont vous assumez
j'ai vu j'ai vu jeu mais je écouter on
me qu'on me prête des attentions donne
des qualificatifs
je vous dis exactement ce que j'en pense
la majorité a besoin de se respecter
entre alliés pour demain trouver
d'autres alliés pour s'élargir encore
déplacement politique en vue oui
simplement bien du diable vauvert est ce
que j'ai ce qu'est ce qu'on peut rêver
d'une renaissance de cette de cette
introduction de proportionnelle pour les
législatives de 2022 moi je crois que
françois bayrou a raison dans la mesure
où après qu'on ait explorer la voie
parlementaire et je les fais moi j'ai
déposé avec mon groupe
des propositions de loi j'ai tenté la
voie parlementaire puisque le moyen de
la république nous y invitait c'était
difficile d'explorer cette voie
parlementaire puisque dans une dernière
année c'est difficile de toucher à la
question du mode de scrutin
mais si on peut par la voie référendaire
et c'est la proposition de françois
bayrou modifier le mode de scrutin pour
qu'ils soient plus représentatifs de la
diversité des françaises dont je parlais
à l'instant
ce serait une très belle avancée et au
delà de ça d'ailleurs
la question sera comment on modernise
les institutions comment on simplifie le
mille feuille territorial auquel plus
personne ne comprend rien
la lie à la campagne départementale et
régionale qui est en train de se
dérouler les électrices et des électeurs
ne s'y retrouvent pas comment on
organise mieux la responsabilité des
élus
comment on répartit mieux les
responsabilités s'entrechoquent on parle
même de
ils réfléchissent à baisser le
pourcentage qui permettrait de se
qualifier au second tour des
législatives alors je sais qu'ils
réfléchissent à ça mais moi je suis pas
suffisamment intelligents pour
comprendre à quoi ça pourrait servir à
quoi selon vous expliquez nous eh ben je
sais pas je sais pas du tout à quoi ça
pourrait servir de bonne façon de
qualifier devrait permettre aussi à des
députés et les oem de repasser en fait
je ne comprends pas l'objectif je pense
que un mode de scrutin une réforme
institutionnelle elle doit être comprise
par les françaises et les français donc
si on fait quelque chose on leur dit
écoute et voilà on va simplifier le
millefeuille on va rééquilibrer les
pouvoirs entre le gouvernement et le
parlement parce que le gouvernement peut
parfois écrasé le parlement et ce n'est
pas sain dans une démocratie il n'a de
gouvernement fort que si le parlement
est fort et on peut leur expliquer qu'on
va simplifier le mille-feuille
territorial ça c'est des choses qui sont
claires et simples bidouiller la
question des seuils de qualification je
vois je vois pas ce qui pourrait
simplifier le l'idée d'une réforme
institutionnelle dans l'esprit des gens
et posez la question aux français
est-ce que vous vous sentez représenté
par l'assemblée nationale du sénat ils
vont répondre non aux trois quarts à 90%
et donc c'est la question de la
représentation qu'il faut qu'il faut
identifier
est-ce que vous pensez que les pouvoirs
sont suffisamment équilibré en france
entre le pouvoir exécutif législatif et
judiciaire
non on est en train de rouler de 2,2
bull d'oser risée montesquieu donc on
voit bien qu'il ya besoin de réformes
démocratiques dans ce pays
ça c'est compréhensible par les français
donc je pense qu'il faut pas prendre les
sujets par le petit bout de la lorgnette
on va parler de natalité puisque
françois bayrou s'est inquiété dans le
journal du dimanche de la faiblesse de
la natalité d'une démographie quelque
peu fragile est ce que pour vous il faut
relancer une politique familiale plus
forte
et est ce que vous allez faire des
propositions on se changera pas la
réouverture des discothèques et on sait
qu'elle se mener aussi
alors c'est vrai mais voilà alors
l'occurrence on va plutôt parler
d'allocations familiales et le quotient
familial
ils les discothèques c'est plutôt le
chemin de parvenir peut être un jour à
la relance de la natalité ce que nous
souhaitons tous françois bayrou il a
posé le problème en bon terme c'est à
dire en termes économiques et sociaux un
pays n'est fort que si sa démocratie et
fort cette démographie est forte
un pays n'est fort que si sa protection
sociale peut être financée par un plus
grand nombre de salariés
or on voit bien que alors que la france
avait une démographie qui est supérieure
à celle de l'allemagne jusqu'au milieu
des années 2000 aujourd'hui parce que on
a moins confiance en l'avenir mais aussi
parce qu'on a complètement déstructuré
la politique familiale
effectivement on fait moins d'enfants
pourquoi vous faites moi un enfant
d'abord parce que vous pouvez pas les
faire garder convenablement parce qu'il
faut qu'on ait de nouveau une relance de
l'activité des gardes d'enfants sur les
crèches sur les assistantes maternelles
ensuite parce que il ya un problème de
logement dans notre pays c'est le
premier budget des français parfois vous
hésité à faire un enfant supplémentaire
parce que vous pouvez pas ni loué ni
acheter un logement plus grand parce que
vous n'en avez pas les moyens et puis
surtout la proposition que nous on a
porté à trois reprises sur trois budgets
successifs et nous avions été battus à
l'assemblée malheureusement il faut
revenir aux allocations familiales et au
quotient familial d'avant hollande et
même d'avant sarkozy puisque le premier
coup qui a été porté à la politique
familiale c'était 2010 suite à la crise
financière de 2000
8900 suite il ya un deuxième cours 2015
qui a été portée par françois hollande
où vous avez plafonner les allocations
familiales mais avec des plafonds
tellement bas qu'aujourd'hui énormément
de classe moyenne ne peuvent plus en
bénéficier et vous avez mis des niveaux
de quotient familial qui permet de payer
moins d'impôts quand on a des enfants
l'idée c'est pas que des gens qui
viennent 50000 euros par mois tous des
allocs
le but ça évidemment pas ça il faut
juste reconnaître que quel que soit son
salaire qu'on soit en très grande
détresse sociale ou qu'on soit
simplement un couple qui travaillent
tous les deux l'arrivée d'un enfant
déséquilibrer le budget familial de
valeurs traditionalistes de la famille
enfin jure aujourd'hui à des familles
qui sont les familles dites
traditionnelles les familles qui sont
homoparentales il ya des familles qui
sont monoparentales le la question de la
famille ne s'est pas le les choix de vie
des uns et des autres et donc d'une
politique familiale qui voudrait
privilégier un choix de vie plutôt qu'un
autre
c'est savoir comment l'enfant paraît et
vous allez reproposer ça dans le budget
vous allez faire des propositions avant
ou plfss exactement on a lancé des
groupes de travail déjà depuis longtemps
sur ce sujet c'est un c'était d'ailleurs
un des grands combats de l'atelier
limaces qui maintenant est entré au
gouvernement et nous allons reprendre ce
flambeau
oui une petite question qui a très
justement aussi ou ou mépris supposé de
certains lrm est ce que vous avez pu
apaiser les tensions en ile-de-france on
les disait grande
oui oui lol oeuvrant dans la
constitution des listes valeurs là pour
le coup je ne parle pas de mépris de
l'om ni du modem il n'importe quel autre
composante de la majorité
quand on fait des listes tous les six
ans c'est compliqué parce que les
élections régionales sont d'élise par
département par région il faut faire de
la place à des générations nouvelles à
la société civile donc à la fin jamais
personne n'est content donc c'est
toujours compliqué on a du modem parti
avec laurent saint martin est ce que
c'est très clair initiale et non non
c'est pas clair du tout moi comme j'ai
dit à plusieurs reprises je suis pas
favorable au principe d'exclusion parce
que c'est le faire passer des élus du
statut de traître à celui de martyrs
c'est plutôt une promotion sociale
en revanche il faut être très clair sur
le fait qu' il ne porte en aucun cas la
parole du modem mais seulement celles de
leurs intérêts ils ont gouverné avec moi
pendant six ans ils ont voté 100 % de
mes délibération je comprendrais pas
qu'il fasse campagne contre moi ce n'est
pas eux qui ne sont pas logiques avait
d'ailleurs le les socialistes à la
région ile-de-france avaient voté 97 %
des délibérations mais parce que là je
crois pas qu'elle aurait proposé une
alliance
non mais vraiment faut se dire la vérité
elle avait besoin de montrer qu'elle
avait quand même des gens de la majorité
présidentielle à ses côtés c'est pour ça
qu'elle a essayé de les garder
moi je suis favorable à ce que en aucune
manière le mouvement démocrate ma
famille de pensée ce grand courant de
pensée de la vie politique française ne
puisse être ambigu il ya des gens qui
font des choix personnels pour des
raisons assez concrète et matérielles ce
qu'il faut se dire les choses et bien
très bien parce que là ils représentent
eux-mêmes et pas notre famille de pensée
et une dernière question de l'allégeance
entre valdes alors oui exactement là qui
pour lequel il ya un sondage qui est qui
et paris qui donnent le candidat du rn
devant marc fesneau ministre et membre
éminent du modem est ce qu'il faut
craindre à ce que votre seule chance de
victoire puisse se briser lors je crois
qu'il a une vraie chance de victoire on
centre val de loire vous avez raison
parce que on le voit dans les enquêtes
d'opinion le l'implantation de longue
date de marc fesneau mais aussi de
jacqueline gourault de richard ramos
dont d'un grand nombre de deux
démocrates engagés dans cette région
pays certes ces gens sont identifiés et
on voit bien ce qu'est leur manière
d'être et de faire de la politique mais
vous avez aussi le
région bretagne vous avez la région pays
de loire il ya bruno bonnell en auvergne
rhône-alpes qui va vous créer une
surprise
je suis certain parce que c'est une
personnalité très intéressante
le front national le front national est
national et je vais vous dire ma crainte
c'est que même y soit encore plus haut
que les enquêtes d'opinion ne le disent
aujourd'hui donc remporté la région
pour marc fesneau il fait son travail
pour rassembler le plus largement
possible
la question sera de savoir au second
tour si les uns et les autres nous
savons prendre nos responsabilités crs
quand on est capable de bâtir des
alliances là aussi entre des personnes
différentes
pas pour faire barrage au front national
et parce que le front national ne serait
pas bien géré cette région il
n'apportera rien de plus là où il dirige
au fond rien n'a été changé en rien
n'était changé en matière de sécurité en
matière d'emploi en matière de
développement économiques en matière de
réchauffement climatique
il faut regarder au soir du premier tour
et est capable de se dire est ce qu'on
peut faire des alliances la question se
posera dans les autres france le luthier
oui assez naturellement je vois pas
l'intérêt de s'entêter à refuser des
alliances parce qu'on est en train de
jouer la présidence de la république
plutôt que la présidence de la région la
question se posera en ile de france
également
soyons capables de rassembler et en tout
cas soyons capables aussi de prendre
tous nos responsabilités pour faire en
sorte que si un risque de victoire du
front national au curé chacun accepte
les alliances est en tout cas accepte de
tout mettre en oeuvre et c'était le sens
des initiatives qui ont été prises en
région provence alpes côte d'azur prenne
ses responsabilités pour éviter le pire
merci beaucoup merci patrick mignola
d'avoir était notre invité ce matin
merci j'ai bien regardé à une de la voix
du nord un sentiment de liberté c'est à
la une de votre journal ce matin j'ai
dit est aussi belle merci beaucoup
[Musique]